now to the latest fallout from the fbi
search of mar-a-lago according to a
letter obtained by cbs news the nation's
top intelligence official says there
will be a review of the documents found
in former president trump's possession
they want to determine if u.s national
security has been put at risk senior
investigative correspondent catherine
herridge has more catherine good morning
good morning john the new risk
assessment by the u.s intelligence
community will determine which records
seized by the fbi at mar-a-lago are
classified at the potential national
security implications if they fell into
the wrong hands
over the weekend the mar-a-lago fallout
spilled over the nation's top
intelligence official avril haynes said
her office will conduct a classification
review of the documents and assessment
of the potential risk to national
security he could be putting our
national security at risk he could be
putting the lives of individual people
who work for the united states at risk i
understand he turned over a lot of
documents he should have turned over all
of them
friday's release of the heavily redacted
affidavit used to obtain the warrant for
the mar-a-lago search revealed 15 boxes
returned to the national archives in
january included 67 documents marked
confidential the lowest level 92 marked
secret and another 25 marked top secret
among the most sensitive government
records with restricted access including
hcs intelligence gathered from
operatives and fisa intelligence
processed through a national security
court but trump questions the timing and
denies anything improper i did nothing
wrong they brought many many fbi agents
in all right before the midterms on face
the nation republican governor larry
hogan called for more transparency about
the fbi search on the one hand it could
be uh as some republicans think just a
you know just a political witch hunt on
the other hand it could be really
serious
you know federal felonies
in what may be a break for trump's legal
team a florida federal judge indicated
her preliminary intent to appoint a
special master that would oversee the
review of materials seized august 8
rather than the fbi but she says that
may not be her final ruling
the district judge at trump appointee
has ordered the justice department to
provide a more detailed receipt of the
items seized at mar-a-lago by tuesday
another hearing is scheduled thursday in
florida tony
all right catherine thank you very much